It's that time of the year where CPAs and
accountants will sit with their clients, entrepreneurs,
and tell them, "Hey, Mr. and Mrs. Entrepreneur,
you should consider giving some money back
to charity because it benefits you when it
comes down to taxes."
So as much as you do want to give back to
charity because it benefits you tax-wise,
depending on the country you live in, today
I want to talk to you about why you should
consider giving back to the community as an
entrepreneur and how to give back to the community.
So if you're wondering where I'm at right
now, in the background, I'm at Bakersfield
airport, with Mario.
It is truly one of the smallest airports,
Bakersfield, great city.
My buddy back here in a paper plane kid, and
we had to shoot a video because tomorrow is
a video that's due.
So let me get right into it.
Listen, there's two ways you give back to
the community.
One is money, one is your time.
So why should you consider giving back to
the community?
There's really five points, and very simple
points on why you should consider giving back
to the community.
#1:
The most important one in my opinion is law
of reciprocity.
Let me tell you what's the law of reciprocity.
I truly believe the more I give, the more
I get in return.
Not an expectation, I just feel good things
happen to me, the more I give.
I'm a big believer in the law of reciprocity.
I don't know how I'm going to get this thing
in return.
Maybe someday someone's going to do something
for my son, my daughter, my family, somebody
close to me that is going to benefit me, but
I believe in the law of reciprocity.
#2
The second benefit that every time I participate
in any kind of way of giving back to the community
is I build so many new relationships.
It's very weird.
We were just in Hawaii doing something with
Foresters, and we were building a school,
and we were painting some walls.
And I was giving the color pink.
I'm painting this chair pink.
It was hilarious.
And we made such incredible relationships
with people that we still communicate with
online.
But it doesn't matter what it is.
Every single time I've given back to any kind
of charity, there's always been an opportunity
to build new relationships.
#3
The other part when you give back to charity
is you'll learn a new skill set.
You learn something new, when you're giving
back.
There's something that you're learning, whether
that charity, whatever they stand for, you're
learning something about the charity or learning
something that you can benefit yourself.
Maybe they're telling you, "Hey, what we do
is we help families test for this."
So now you learn about that new skill set.
#4
The fourth one I will tell you would be your
heart.
Like your heart gets, I don't know how to
explain this to you.
Your heart goes in the mode of giving back,
so it almost becomes gentler, and it gets
in the mood of understanding everybody else's
position in a different way, when you do give
back, and you're around other people that
want to give back.
So it influences you.
If you're somebody that's extremely strong
and rigid, with a military background, charity
would do very good things to you.
#5
And fifth point, simple.
Self Esteem.
You feel like you're making a difference.
It keeps you grounded.
You feel like the world needs you.
You feel like you are needed in a way.
You realize how incredible of a life you have
as an entrepreneur.
Do give back.
So, you know, those five things alone, outside
of the tax benefit, I highly recommend why
you ought to consider giving back.
Now, the question that a lot of people ask
is, "Pat, how do I give back?
What do I do?"
I got, how many points do I have here, Mario?
I think I wrote 11 points here on how to give
back, and you can pick and choose on how to
do them.
So, the first one, we were having a conversation
earlier today at this restaurant.
And I ate some plantains.
The plantains were amazing at this place.
It was amazing.
We had a great time there.
But one of the guys asked me a question, Alejandro
asked me a question and he said, "Hey, what
do you do when your family starts asking you
for all this money, and they want to borrow
money and all this other stuff?"
I said, "I don't believe in lending money
to people, especially friends and family."
Because I believe it's the fastest way to
create an enemy.
He said, "What do you mean by that?"
I said, because if you lend money, and you
say yes, they love you, but it's guaranteed
that they're most likely going to come back
and later on ask for what?
More money.
And at some point you have to say what?
No.
So if you give money from yourself to somebody
else, your family's not going to be happy
that you give money to somebody else, possibly,
if they're lending money.
And then two, if you do loan money to friends
and family, you will typically see them avoiding
you at the next family gathering, and you
feel uncomfortable because you look like you're
a bill collector, and they kind of don't like
you.
It's just not a fun game to lend money.
So I like to give money.
Let me explain to you what I mean by this.
So if somebody asks me, "Pat, can you lend
me $5,000?"
I'll generally say, "No, I won't lend you
$5,000, but I'll give you $300.
You don't ever have to give it back."
So, they don't like me, they don't hate me.
It's a very neutral position, but I gave some
money back, and I'm good to go.
Why?
Because I'm not in the game - I don't think
the biggest benefit is just money being given
away, although money you need to give away,
because some organizations need money to do
their work that they do.
#1
This is why my #1 point on how to give back
is to teach a new skill set.
Teach a new skill set.
Go help somebody and give back to your community
by teaching something you're very, very good
at.
Teach somebody else how to do it.
What could that be?
I don't know.
How to get ready for a job interview.
Go and teach people how to be prepared for
a job interview.
Go and sit down with 50 people and tell them,
I'm going to interview you, and you're going
to know exactly what types of questions you're
going to ask, and I'm going to prepare you
on how to ask those questions.
Great.
Give back by teaching people how to put a
resume together.
Give back by sitting down and teaching how
to sell something.
Give back by teaching some kind of new skill
set that you have.
Social media, whatever it is.
But give back to your community by teaching
something you know.
It could be music.
It could be piano.
It could be guitar.
It doesn't matter.
Free lessons for soccer for kids.
Somehow, some way, give back and teach a new
skill set, because that lasts.
I think skill set lasts and it generates and
gives them freedom.
So #1 is skill set.
#2
Number two is volunteer your time at a hospital
or school.
It's a very easy thing to do.
Any time you go to a school and you're giving
back, whether it's Big Brother or you know,
somebody that needs some kind of help.
I've done many, many things with school, where
I was hired to go and, not hired, I didn't
ask for the money.
It was a LAUSD.
I went and spoke to the troubled kids that
had the anklets and they were in prison.
They did time, or they were 13-year-old girls
that were pregnant.
Or drug dealers and they put me through a
six month program that I would come down every
other week, and I would take these kids and
we would talk about the biggest thing they
struggled with.
And they would tell me how much they struggle
with pornography or pressure of having sex,
or drugs, or joining gangs, or fights, or
arguments with parents, or what do I do when
my mom and dad, my mom's on drugs, my dad's
on drugs, my parents aren't there, I'm living
on the streets, I'm this, I'm that.
All this stuff.
And it was one way for them to know that somebody
out there at least cares about them.
The reason why that's very important is because
when I was 13 years old, and my parents got
a divorce, and I was a troubled kid, I was
recruited by a basketball league in Echo Park
called New Century Basketball association.
And they got together all the troubled kids
and gangsters and all this other stuff.
And we played basketball together.
So that made a very big impact in my life
to know an older man named Vladimir, not an
older man at that time, he was 20 years older
than me.
Vladimir was like an older brother to me.
And he gave me direction and hope to know
that somebody believed in me.
That played a very big role in my life.
So you don't even know who you're going to
be making an impact in their life.
And one of the simplest ways is hospitals
and schools.
#3
Another way is organize a food drive.
Mario, I don't know how many times we've done
this, but I remember for many many years when
were in L.A. every Christmas morning at 5:30
in the morning, we'd go to [Mario - Union
Rescue Mission in downtown L.A.], Downtown
L.A. at 5:30 in the morning and we would go
and give away toothpaste, toothbrush, pillows,
towels, and then we'd go to McDonald's and
buy 100, 150 McMuffins and come back and give
food and blankets.
Another group that would go there would sing
carols to them.
It was just fascinating.
Food Drive, because sometimes you'd be amazing
how many people just need a simple meal.
Typically, when people come to me and they
tell me, when somebody's begging on the streets
and they ask me for money, I always offer
food.
I say, "I'll buy you a meal."
And if they say, "No, I just want money,"
I don't give them money, because then I know
what's taking place with the money.
But I say, "Why do you need money?"
Oh, because of food.
Okay, let me go buy you food.
"Oh, you know what?"
Then I know exactly where they're at.
But if they want me to buy them food, no problem.
I was in Chicago one night.
It was 1:00 in the morning.
I landed, I'm so hungry.
I go to this only pub that was open late at
night, and they were offering steak.
And this one homeless man outside, he said,
"Can you give me 20 bucks?"
I said, "Man, you're a big thinker if you're
asking for 20 bucks."
And he said, "Can you give me 20 bucks?"
I said, "No, but I'll buy you a meal."
He said, "No problem, man.
I'm so hungry."
I said, what do you want to have?
He said anything.
I said, "Let's have dinner together."
I take him in the restaurant and the owner
says, "No, he's not welcome here.
He begs outside all the time."
I said, "Look, I'm paying."
He said, "But he can't come inside."
I said, "No problem.
What do you want to order?"
Give him a menu.
He gave him a menu.
And I said, "What do you want?"
He said, I want a prime rib.
I said, "What else do you want?"
He ordered his food.
So they bring my food.
I could eat it inside.
They didn't let him eat inside.
I had them serve his prime rib outside to
him, and the drinks outside to him.
He ate his meal, he was happy.
I ate, I left.
The purpose was served.
And I didn't give him money.
But I did give him food.
There's many ways you can give back that's
going to help people out.
The smallest occasions.
You have no idea how much that means to that
person.
That person's got a stomach full of food that
night to go to sleep and they're good to go.
#4
Fourth way, coach kids.
My brother-in-law, I call him a saint.
I've never met a man like him.
He is so gentle as a man with kids, that every
parent that he was coaching this summer, the
son, Sean, is like a phenome soccer player.
He's an absolute beast of a left - he kicks
with his left food, did you know that?
He's insane.
I mean, when he plays, the team knows they're
going to win.
And so, he was asked by parents after a great
job he did last season, they want him to coach
again.
So he went and coached again.
And so, one of the ways you can coach is if
you have a good tolerance for kids, and you
played high school football or baseball or
basketball or soccer and you know the basic
practice tactics because you were a part of
it, give back.
If you've done some organized sports, that's
one of the ways you can do it.
#5
Help raise money for a certain charity or
a foundation.
Just recently we teamed up with Susan G. Komen
for I don't know how many years.
And Jennifer, my wife, is very instrumental
on the way she's working with Susan G. Komen
and many of the ladies.
So this time we had many, many events across
the country.
I don't know how many events this was.
All over the country we did events.
And money was raised.
I mean, it could have been as small as $250
to raising as much as $11,000, $12,000.
And then that money goes to Susan G. Komen.
Why?
Well, for them, it could be 68% of the money
is used for research and they're going to
find out ways for breast cancer, and my grandmother
had breast cancer, and both of them had to
be, you know, and it's a very emotional and
difficult thing a woman goes through.
And a lot of times you can do simple testing
that, they're educating women on how to test
- I just think it's very important.
So find out what research means a lot to you
and go support that charity.
There's many of them out there that you can
participate with.
Go online and look them up and find something
that means a lot to you, and if you're part
of a company that supports a certain charity,
support them as well.
But on top of that, be able to support other
charities that mean a lot to you.
Support those causes as well.
#6 is elderly homes.
Sometimes elderly homes they just want somebody
to talk to them.
Believe it or not, when you go to elderly
homes, if I can tell you the one question
to ask when you do go to elderly homes is,
here's my favorite question to ask, "What
invention was completely crazy when it happened
in your lifetime?"
And you will have some of the most random
conversations when somebody says, I remember
when they said this one machine was coming
out, that we were going to watch shows on
it.
And it was television.
How was it?
Our first person in the city that had it,
it was crazy.
So when you go there, ask them all sorts of
ways that you can learn from them.
Hey, I'm a Great Depression baby.
How was it?
It doesn't matter.
Somebody could be 95 years old and they're
still able to talk and you're sitting there,
talking to them.
There's a lot you can give back to them.
So that's elderly.
#7: The next one is give money.
It's very simple.
Give money away to different types of things.
And one is I talk about research.
And the other one is giving money away to
certain things that need help.
It doesn't matter what it is.
It could be a local community that they're
building a park for kids.
Great.
Go contribute for them.
#8: Then it's building up local businesses.
This is a simple one.
Find out what local businesses, new local
businesses that got started, and they're just
kind of trying to get it going.
Help them with their business.
Help get the word of mouth out there to help
them out.
It doesn't matter what it is.
I'm always amazed when people don't want to
support new business owners.
Help that person go out there.
If they've got good you like, go tell the
world about it.
You know, you go to a nice restaurant, even
right now while you're watching this, commit
today to posting one small business in your
area that just got started that you like.
It could be a coffee shop.
It could be a restaurant.
It could be a gym you go to that's not the
traditional big gym.
It could be anything that you go to.
Post the link on your Facebook Page, and say
why you like it.
Very simple.
Post it on Twitter and say why you like it.
Simple as that.
It's simple as that on what you need to do.
One, tag it to them.
They'll be grateful you're doing that.
And two, other people will look at you and
say, Man, he or she endorses other small businesses
and supports other businesses.
I like his approach.
I'm wondering what he or she does.
That's you.
#9 Then we have going big.
I'm a big fan of going big.
I think you've got to go make tens if not
hundreds millions of dollars.
Why?
Because the more money you make, the more
money you can give back.
So you've got to go big.
Don't let anybody fool you and tell you that
it's not important to make big money.
If you're a good person, and you're watching
this, and you've got a good heart, and you've
got a giving heart, guess what?
You know what I want people like you to do?
I want you to make tens of millions of dollars.
Because if you make tens of millions of dollars
and you truly have a big heart, you're going
to give lots of money away.
By the way, if you're somebody watching this,
and you say, I'll give money once I start
making money, no you won't.
If you're stingy with $10, you're going to
be stingy with $100,000.
I guarantee you you'll be stingy with $10
million.
So just be in the spirit of giving.
I always remember when one time I was competing
with another guy and he had a nickname of
being a jerk.
And one guy got up and he said something very
interesting.
And we were competing hardcore.
We were good friends.
But he had this nickname that we'd give him.
I didn't think he was a jerk, but other people
thought he was a jerk.
And this one guy got up who he didn't like
this competitor.
And I'm sitting there, there were three of
us.
And one tried to call him out and the other
guy said, you know what happens when you make
money?
Here's all money does to you.
Money just makes you more of what you are
right now.
If you're a jerk, you're a rich jerk.
If you give a lot right now, you'll give a
lot more when you make more money.
It just makes you more of what you are today.
Not much changes.
You just become more of what you are today.
So going big.
Go and make lots of money.
Figure out ways how you can contribute to
society.
#10: The other one is give away books.
Simply give away books.
I don't know how many thousands of books we've
given away.
5,000?
I don't know how many thousands of books we've
given way.
Literally, 5, 6, 7,000 books.
Because I feel the same with somebody can
impact my life by giving me a book.
The way I can help change someone's life,
like I just talked to a kid right now, a young
cat who is a quality guy and I remember when
I spoke to him in Palm Springs and he says,
the book that made the biggest impact on my
life is Laws of Success.
And then somebody else says, another book,
and another book, and another book.
And, you know, you have no idea how big of
an impact you can make in your community if
you give books away.
Go figure out a way on who impacted your life,
at what age, give those books away.
It could be the fact that you don't like the
fact that your parents went through a divorce.
Go buy 50 copies of the Five Love Languages
and give it away to people around you that
mean a lot to you, and you know the husband
and wife are going through a challenge, give
those books away to them.
It could be somebody that you're seeing that
has some drug issues.
Go buy five of those books, and give it away
to somebody that has a drug issue.
Or a depression issue.
Whatever it is.
You'd be amazed how big of an impact you can
make in someone's life by giving some books
away.
#11 - last but not least, surprise a family.
How?
I don't care how you surprise them.
Just surprise them.
[Flight announcement over the loud speaker,
including an announcement about the Galaxy
Note 7, and some ribbing by Patrick to Mario
because he has a Samsung.]
Mario: That should keep me off the plane.
Patrick: It's about safety.
We're trying to make you live a long time.
The last one is surprise a family.
How do you surprise a family?
Make a meal for them.
Surprise them.
Stop by someone's house and, you know, find
out what gifts the kids want and just surprise
them.
This is a very good season, November, December,
to surprise people.
Make people feel good.
Believe me, you will enjoy yourself more if
you go out there and give back during this
season.
So, with that being said, this is the response
to many of you that sent me messages on giving
back, how to give back, and why you should
give back.
So with that being said, if you've got some
ways that you give back, that is different
than what I said, please, post your comment
on the bottom and if you have not subscribed
to this channel, please do so by clicking
on the subscribe button on the bottom.
And this lady doesn't sound like she's going
to stop talking, so I'm going to let you go
with the distraction we got and I'll look
forward to next week's episode from the office
where I've got some exciting things I'm going
to share with everybody.
Take care everybody, bye bye.